Alright. And we have
white again.
OCdt Brusseau 87.
All right, well, another white
game, another E four game.
And let's see what our opponent throws
at us this time.    Well,
once again, my official recommendation is
the Alipin Sicilian. This is is what we are
focusing on in the speedrun we're playing
the alapin and the Mora interchangeably,
and we're facing D five,  which,
as I've indicated many times, is
one of black's two most
reputable responses to the alapin, the
other being Night F Six, which is a smidge
more popular these days. Now,
D five basically leads
to a scandy with the
ponds on C three and C five, which is
clearly in black's favor because the pawn on
C five does the important job of
controlling the center, whereas the pond
on C three has the
unfortunate drawback of preventing the night
from developing to its rightful square.
So if you want to think of it as kind of
a scandal with the move C three,
C five included, you can kind of do that.
Now, of course, the pond on C three also has
a benefit. There is a reason we put it
there. And the reason we put it
there is to prepare the move D four
occupying the center with our pawn.
And I would say,
and I'm pulling this number a little bit out
of my butt, but   any
rating below one
8900. This is
a tremendously dangerous position for black.
It doesn't look that dangerous. It doesn't
even look like white is imposing any kind
of,   uh, threats on
black. But if black mishandles
this position, white gets a massive
initiative. Obviously, the queen on D
Five is far from safe. It can be chased away
in a variety of ways. And one
mistake that people make right off the bat
here in many cases is that
they take on D four
prematurely. And we've won a couple of games
that way. And of course, the
reason that taking on D four is often
inaccurate is because it
opens up the C three square for white's
knight, allowing us to transition
the game into kind of normal scandy
channels, chasing the queen away from D, D
five. And when the queen is chased
away from D five, the pot on D four can then
frequently advance to D five itself. And if
there is a knight on C six, white can
in many cases, develop a pretty
devastating initiative. So I'm impressed
with our opponents. Play Knight. F Six is
the correct move, and we, of
course,   follow up with our own
developing move. We play Night F three,
then we kind of play the semi waiting game,
hoping that black takes on D four and
flinches first.   As
for our other pieces,
where we put them depends
entirely on the
developmental setup that black chooses.
Black has a lot of viable continuations
here.    On a broad
level, the two main lines are
to play Bishop G Four. This is the sort of
very ambitious developing move
and in response to Bishop G four, we have
Bishop E two. We also have this weird move.
Knight B to D two. In order to set up Bishop
C four, we'll decide  if,
uh, our opponent plays it. And
the second approach, which has been popular
pretty recently I actually just faced this
in my blitz session. Uh, right before the
speedrun is the immediate e
six. And this is what Black chooses in
this game. Now, the benefit
of E Six is that Black
quickly accelerates,
uh, his or her Kingside development.
Black's idea, broadly speaking, is to
play Bishop E seven and quickly tuck the
king away on the kingside. And you might
say, well, what about the C eight bishop?
Well, the C eight bishop, uh, can be
deployed oftentimes on the long diagonal
black and play B six, bishop B seven or
black and just keep it on C eight for the
time being. Not every piece needs to be
distributing the COVID vaccine. Now, if you
watched carefully,  uh, my actual blitz
games, you will know what the move is in
this position.   If you're not familiar
with typical allopon ideas, this is
a very hard move to just figure
out, right? If you were to play based
on general principles, you
might come up with a move
like Bishop E three.
Or maybe Bishop D three. And Bishop. D
three, by the way, is one of the main lines.
But the most meat on the bone can be
extracted not with a bishop move,
but with a night move. Now? Uh, you might
say. Well, where are we going to go with the
night until we go night BD two. Not Quite.
We actually go night to a three.
Very, very typical move in the Alipin.
And the idea is actually
threefold. The
main point, as you can probably
guess, is to play a well
timed knight. B, five, that
threatens a family fork on c,
seven. And when combined
with the move, bishop F four exerts. Very
serious pressure on Black's Queen side. So
that's idea number one. Idea
number two is to use the knight as
an anchor piece and prepare
the aggressive development of the Light
Squid bishop to C four, which is also a
tempo move. The third idea comes
in handy in the event that Black plays the
move a six, which is one of the main
lines here. A six prevents night. B
five. Who can tell me what the third
idea is? The third idea
is just a move that we play in the
event of a six.
We don't play. Bishop c four.
There.   We don't play night c. Two.
NC Two is a little bit passive. We actually
play night c four.   And
why. Specifically, in response to a
six?   Well, because you should notice
that the B six square is a massive
weakness. In that case, And NYC Four
Threatens Another Fork On B Six,
and It's not so easy for Black to
defend the square on B
six while keeping his pieces
active, because the last thing Black wants
to do is just drop the queen back to D
eight. That's passive, and that often gives
White an advantage. And yet that's often
precisely what Black has to do in order to
protect these key squares. C takes d four.
Now, here   we refrain
from the move a lot of people are tempted
by, which is bishop C four.
Tempting move. But it's wrong because the
queen has this very nasty check on E
four. So bishop C four is
wrong. Instead, we make a different
intermezzo. We play night b five.
We play night b five. Now, this is the
main idea of the previous move.
And you might say, well, wait a minute.
What about Queen E? Four. Check here. Well,
queen e four. Check. Doesn't actually solve
the problem of knight C seven. After Queen
E. Four. Check. We play bishop e two. And
even though night C seven doesn't fork the
king and the queen anymore, it still forks
the king and the rook. So it's still a
massive threat, and Black has no choice
but to protect the C seven square. There are
several ways to do that. The main move in
this position is to drop the queen all,
uh, the way back to D eight.
Black can also do it with the bishop. And
that's exactly what our opponent just did,
bishop to D six. But this is already a
serious inaccuracy. And this hands
White,  uh, a pretty
sizable positional advantage. It's not
a terrible move. Bishop D six
is actually okay,
but it gives us
a, uh, major advantage and an initiative.
So there's a couple of things that White can
do. The
Soviet schoolboy method
would be to say, okay, well, we
can just play knight takes B six check, and
we can collect the bishop pair, and then we
can recapture the pondante four. And it
should make sense to everybody that in the
resulting position, white is positionally
better. We have the bishop pair,  uh,
with an open
center. Our bishops are nicely, uh,
placed. We can bring one bishop to D three
and the other bishop maybe to G five. And
Black still has to deal with the issue
that his remaining bishop is stuck behind
the pawn chain. So Knight takes d six.
Check. Nothing wrong with it. But in the
spirit of the elephant, we can try to
extract as much juice out
of this position as possible.
Especially given that we know the queen is a
very bad defender. When the queen
defends a minor piece, that
construction is always
going to be prone to a lot of different
tactics. So what move can we
try on the basis of that? Well, a lot of
you are coming up with the idea of pushing C
four. The problem with C four
is that it's a very leaky move. C
four opens up the diagonal and
allows bishop B four check
intrametzo.  Then Black
trades the bishop on B four and drops the
queen back to D eight. It's not the end of
the world for White, but it's not
effective. Also, after C
four, black can drop the queen into C
five. Kind of a weird square,
but I don't see a good way to attack the
queen when it lands on C five.
So instead of pushing C four, we can do the
same thing, the same exact thing.
But while we're at it, we can continue
our development and make a more
serious threat against Black's queen. The
move is bishop to C four.
I m might say, I don't get
how that differs substantively
from the move C four. Well, first of all,
it's a developing move, and that, in and of
itself is already good.
But where you see the real benefit of
playing bishop C four over the move C four
is that if Black plays now the move
Queen to C five, we have
kept open the possibility of then playing
C takes D four. And everybody should see, by
the way, why the bishop cannot be captured.
The reason is that we recapture on D six,
and that is, once again, a fork, uh, on the
queen and the king.   Now,
Black still has the move queen E four
check. And that might seem scary to you,
but queen E four check is a total paper
tiger. We can block that check with our
bishop.   We can even move the
king away. And Black's lack of
development is going to cost him, um,
very dearly, because the bishop on
D six has to remain on that
diagonal in order to prevent
NC seven check. So in the resulting
position, black has to
tread very carefully in order to
avoid losing more material.
So king F one here is
possible, but I want to play this a
little bit less adventurously. I think that
we should just play a simple move.
Actually, we can play bishop to E
three. Talk about sexy. Bishop
E three might even be the best move in the
position.   I was going to propose
bishop E two. But
Bishop E three is a well
known idea in these types of lines. Believe
it or not, I've seen a line where Bishop E
three is the main theoretical move. I will
show you after the game. And Bishop E
three looks fantastic because guess what?
We're just completing our development.
We're just making developing
moves. And this is not as
outlandish as it might seem if you
understand the mechanism of how this move
works.   Right. The fact that the
D six bishop is hanging with a fork is
so important. Black has to spend a tempo
defending the bishop or moving it. And
after that, we will finally recapture the
pawn on D four, and we will have a
massive lead in development. A
monster knight on B five and
the queen on E four is now more
vulnerable than ever. Because when you've
got a queen that's out in the center like
this and none of the other pieces are
developed, the queen is liable to get
trapped or get attacked. And Black
is already in serious trouble. It took us
nine moves.    King e
seven. Whoa.   That is
a surprise.   And
again, we have to switch gears
seamlessly.    Stage one
was the fun part, right? We brought
all our pieces out. We were using
tactics. Stage two is a little bit less
glamorous. This is where we actually reap
the rewards of our fine opening
play, but we actually just play
it very simple here. So first question we
should resolve is whether or
not we should take the bishop on D six.
Should we snap this bishop off the board,
or do we take on D
four straight away? Well, the
answer, I think, can largely be yielded
intuitively. Knight takes D six doesn't
really have a downside. We get the bishop
pair,  and especially in the
context of Black's previous move, don't
you want to drive the king out to D six
and then in the resulting position? We
definitely want to snap the bishop off in
the resulting position. We don't want to
trade queens here. Is white
better in that endgame? Absolutely. White is
still better in that endgame. But we want to
go for checkmate. With no development on the
king sitting on D six, what do we actually
recapture on D four with?
Well, we can't take with the bishop
because the bishop is pinned.
Taking with the pawn closes
down the D file, and the D file is going to
be the main attacking avenue.
We, of course, want to take on D four
with the knight. And it should be very
clear to you that in that position,
after king takes D six, knight takes D
four, queen takes D two
is as non
threatening as a move can possibly
get, because we can go night F five
check, and we're going to have checkmate
seven ways to Sunday. There,
uh, we don't even have to calculate it. I'm
not calculating that line. We'll cross that
bridge if we get there. But there is no way
the Black can get away with queen takes she
two in that position.    And looking
more specifically as we take on
D four with a knight, after queen takes she
two. I think night F five double check leads
to forced mate
double check followed by a check on D six,
and we hunt the king down. Pretty
straightforward. Now, what's funny is that
after queen takes she too,
if you didn't see night F five
check,   the crazy thing is, even a move
like rook f one preserves
a, uh, devastating attack against Black's
king. So it's just a pawn?
It's just a pawn. But I hope black takes
it so we could have fun. King e seven, good
play by our opponent, king E seven, I think,
is the only way for Black to stay
alive. They have to move the king away from
the potential discovered check. Now, again,
this is the part of the game where a
lot of players struggle, because you're kind
of rearing to go. You're looking for the
knockout, but there is no knockout.
We don't have enough pieces in the
attack. Now, I would briefly check if
I were white, uh, a move like
knight A five. Check. Maybe try to go bishop
C five. But none of that works because the
bishop is also pinned. And that's the key
insight. The bishop is pinned. We need to
unpin ourselves, and the way that we do that
is by simply castling kingside.
Now, this accomplishes several things. As I
said, it unpins the bishop, but it
also prepares to deploy the rook.
Our next move is very likely to be rook to
E one in order to harass the
queen and try to force the queen out of
e four. And by forcing
the queen out of e four, we're also
opening up the efile and setting up
possibilities of NF, uh, five check, et
cetera. Rook to d eight. Still
good defensive play by our opponent. Well,
we continue deploying our pieces with the
rookie e one. Of course, we are
totally not afraid of the move
e five here. There is no way that E five
is going to work out for Black, given his
total lack of development.  In
fact, I think after e five, the clinical
move is Bishop e three to
G five, and this might actually
happen. That forces the queen
away, and the queen has nowhere to
go such that it
maintains contact with the E five pawn.
Black is going to lose that pawn on e five
with check. Now, do we have a threat here?
All, uh, e five is played. So, once
again, why did our opponent play E five?
Well, our opponent sees the fact that the
knight can't move, and he gets excited.
Something that you should notice is
that Black does not even have a threat.
We could literally play a four here, and we
would still probably be winning.
Why is that? Because if Black
plays e takes D four, we just recapture with
the bishop, and the queen on e four is
pinned. Anytime you have alignment between
the king and the queen, that is
an incredibly vulnerable tactical situation.
But that doesn't mean we're going to play a
four. We are going to move the bishop away
onto the best possible square. What is the
best possible square for the bishop? Well,
it's not f four. I can see some people
falling for bishop F four that
simply blunders the bishop on F four. Of
course, the best square is G five because it
also pins the knight, and it most
importantly, forces the queen away. What
squares do the queen have at its
disposal? Not many f five
is covered. F four is covered.
So those are the two squares where the queen
keeps contact with the E five pawn.
Queen G six or queen G four
is forced. And then, of course, we
grab the pawn on e five. We force the king
back to F eight, and who sees the
crushing move in that resulting position?
Again, a direct consequence of the fact that
Black has not developed any part of their
queen side.
Yeah, G six. Sorry, if I said G
five,   what's the move after
queen G six? Rook takes e five,
king f eight. Of course, the move is
94 to E six, an elementary
discovery against the rook on D eight, and
that leads to force checkmate.
Simple, straightforward attacking
chess.     But
what really made the wheels of the attack
turn,   first of all,
is the fact that we took on D Six at the
right moment. So we forced Black to waste a
bunch of tempeh moving back and forth.
But castles and rookie one, these are the
two moves that you should really pay
attention to, and you should make sure that
you would play these types of moves in
your own game, that you wouldn't get tempted
by some speculative attacking
approach.   The role of
patience in attacking cannot be
overstated. And this is a good lesson, a
good introductory lesson in that regard.
This is
GG. Now Black and Try. Rook takes D
four. But then we just
recapture with a pawn, preserving
all of our threats. And then even D takes e
five is crushing.
Yeah. Simple game, 14 moves. You
can see that we are not compromising on the
danger level   just
because we're playing an Alopen rather than
amora. I promise you that. And I think you
can see that in effect.   If I
was watching this on YouTube, I would ponder
the idea that these are paid actors. Your
ideas always work out well for now,
right? And one thing that you can
observe and I think this is one of the
reasons people like the speedrun, is slowly
but surely the games start to become
a little bit less smooth. Right now, it just
seems like I play the moves in the opening
and then they work perfectly. And we're
winning by move 15 every single time. And
we are, when we hit
16, 1700, even a little
bit earlier than that,   you
can start to see that my ideas don't
always work out perfectly. I make some
inaccuracies.  The games
last a lot longer on average, but
that's, I think, part of what makes it fun.
Okay. Queen takes e one. Well, that gives up
the queen. That actually might be the best
that Black can do.   Crazyly
enough, that's how lost he is.
But obviously
it goes without saying that the night on D
four is untouchable because the E five pawn
is pinned and our attack simply continues.
Just because we're up a queen doesn't mean
that we are pausing our attack.
Black cannot even get a rook and a piece
for the queen. What's going on here?
Well, we have a queen for a rook, which
is a totally overwhelming material
advantage.   But more
importantly, we have a raging attack on the
black king if the
knight  comes out to d
seven. If the knight comes out to d
seven, how are we going to
actually win the pawn on e five? There is
a very nice move and a
very instructive move against
987, which has been played. Who can
spot this move? An
important concept to keep in mind, right?
Using your pawns to just
blast through the gates here. The
best move is just to play
f four. Very nice. F, uh, four is
crushing. Notice how
we're using the queen as the pinning
piece and we're using the pawn as
the main attacker, and we're using the pin
against the nine on e seven sorry,
the 906 to
ensure that after e four, we
can just pick up the pawn on e four.
Now, what should we do here?
In order to figure that out, you should
understand that the ultimate goal for White,
the fastest way to win a game like this is
just to open up as many files as
possible. It's not really to win pawns. We
already have an extra queen. So
what's the best way to just blast
open the e file? The f
file. As many files as you can. It's
not bishop takes f six. It's
just f takes e five. This is the
simplest way. And this should
make sense, too, because after
Hgef, we've opened
up both the e and the f file,
and the king has no safe haven. If it moves
to the f file, we follow it to the
f file with our queen. If it
moves back to f uh, eight, then queen e
seven, check, leads to checkmate. If king
D six, then still queen e seven. Everywhere
the king goes, we just tail it with our
queen. And this is made in three moves. We
don't even take the rook on d eight. We take
on f seven and take on G seven with
checkmate. Bang, and then
bang. And that's the best way to finish the
game.
So, again, a simple game.
But if you're watching and
you're finding this to be boring, try to
focus on kind of building
fundamentals and making sure that your
fundamentals are in place, that you would
play the same moves that I played in this
game.     So a little bit of
opening theory here. A little bit
of opening theory.   D
five is impressive from someone
at his level. A lot of people know the
basics, which is great. So after
d four, knight f six,
knight f three leads to
an incredibly
famous, uh,   and well studied theoretical
position. E six is a good move.   Um,
and I had this recently against
Argentinary Geyse in Am Chess. I also had
this in a classical game in the US. Open,
uh, against the GM, where I
won a nice game, we actually had this
exact position.   Now,
if I remember correctly, black's two best
moves in this position are considered to be,
first of all, A six, which
I mentioned during the game.
And here the line goes, night
C four.   How
is Black going to defend B six? Who
can tell me the best way
for Black to defend the B
six square? Can Black do it
while developing a piece?
Yeah. Knight B eight
to D seven. This is an important move,
and Black's next move is very likely to be B
seven. B five, chase the Knight away from
C four and prepare the deployment
of the LightSquared. Bishop to B. Seven.
Now, you might wonder, let's
say you're a
GM, and
where do you go from here? Let's say you
want to study this position. Well, that's
where opening books are so
valuable. You would just pull out the
alipin book, which I know all of you guys
have, and you would check what the authors
recommend in this position. That's really
all you do in many cases, to deepen your
knowledge,   uh, of of
important theoretical positions. And that's
what I can do right now. Just pull out the
book.
And orienting
yourself in these long opening
books can be difficult, but the table of
contents usually has   a
pretty good overview of
all of the pertinent
lines.  Okay, 242.
There we go.   Yep, I see it
now. So what the authors recommend
in Squeezing the Sicilian
squeezing the Sicilian
is     yeah, night
A. Uh,
page 292. Knight C
four, NBD Seven. They just
give Bishop E two,
and they say here it deserves attention
for White to try A four,
restricting Black's possibilities on the
queen side. So, interesting,     uh,
alternative, but their main line is Bishop E
two. And now they give a bunch of
analysis, but their main line is C takes D
four, knight takes D four.
Now, Queen takes D
two allows Bishop F three with
a massive initiative for White.
And they give a bunch of
analysis here with the
upshot that White has huge
compensation for the pawn.
And the main line here
is E Five trying to force the queen
trade. Now we sink our
teeth into F five. And
they say that in the event of the queen
trade, white is a slight advantage,
according to some correspondence game
fill on against
Salon from 2008. Knight Ft six. Check. Yeah,
clearly White is slightly better here.
And if Black tries to trade on his
own terms with knight C Five,
then according to the authors,
you drop the knight back to E three,
you force the queen trade,
and they claim that White is slightly
better in this position due to
the improved placement of the night on
C four.   So
this is really what opening study
starts to look like when you cross, like, a
certain level. I wouldn't recommend   a
600 to purchase a book
like this and spend hours digging
around in opening theory,
but that's really all there is
to it when you want to deepen your knowledge
of critical theoretical lines
so asics might not fully equalize.
Our opponent plays C takes D
four, which is, of course, and the engine
does support that. This is a pretty recent
book. There definitely are
holes in that book. It's it was written in
2020, so already the engines have
gotten stronger. But you can still
very much rely on
resources, I would say, from 2015
onwards, if you're anybody except
Magnus Carlson, any book written
past 2015 on the opening
by a solid player, by a GM,
you can not necessarily
trust verbatim, but you can use
as a base.   So C
takes D four, we play night B five,
threatening knight C seven. And here, of
course, came a massive mistake
by Black conceptually the
move, bishop D six makes sense. Black tries
to defend the square on C seven while
developing a piece, but doing so with the
bishop is just a very inefficient use of
resources due to this
very nasty response. Bishop c
four.   So what was the correct move
in this position? The only correct move
is knight to A six. Very typical
move. And night A six
is ubiquitous
across many different openings
where A night lands on B five.
And what comes to mind as a comparison is
the Jabba London, which is a totally
unrelated opening, but an opening that also
features, in many cases, the move
night B five as early as move
four.   And here you
often see Black going night A six, which is
a nice square from which to defend the C
seven pawn.
Um,
A six is a move.
No, I mentioned queen D seven, but that's in
a different position.   Uh, queen D
seven is the move.
If Black plays in this position, night
C six,    and
White plays night B five, which I
actually just had in a blitz game here.
Queen D seven, I think, is the topical move
that's supposed to equalize, but don't quote
me on that. You can do your own research
here. So, CD four,
NB five, knight A six
is the main move. And here,
White normally plays queen
takes D four, although you can
also play night B takes D four. And I think
in all cases, white is better. I
think white is solidly better in
this position. This, I think, is what the
authors recommend.    And if
memory serves me right, they give this line,
bishop E seven, bishop E five, check
bishop D seven. And now something to keep
the tension, like queen E two and black is
just a little bit cramped. And the queen on
D five   in such
positions, uh, is obviously very
vulnerable. Like if Black Castles and White
Castles rook D one is coming to a
theater near you, and that's going to. Cause
massive anguish to black screen, white is
slightly better. It's more comfortable to
play this with white.
So   hopefully this
opening overview isn't too boring. In any
case, bishop D six, bishop C four leads to
massively unpleasant consequences for
black.     Um, well, king d
eight. King D eight is a huge concession,
right? If you have to go king D eight to
protect the c seven square, I'm just going
to take on D four and say, hey, your king is
terrible and I'm just going to continue
developing.   Right?
So, bishop D six, bishop C four,
queen E four, check. And bishop e three is a
sexy move. And I wanted to show you another
line where bishop e three is the main
theoretical move. Yeah, the engine likes
queen takes D four, which is a totally
legitimate move, because after queen takes D
four, knight f 64. I'll tell you what I
missed. I thought that after
bishop e five, black is
stable. But here there is an incredibly
strong move. Who can find this move?
There's a hidden move here that wins
material for white, and it's not f four. I
know some of you are probably thinking f uh,
four. I can guarantee it.
It's not f four.
And the reason it's not F, uh, four
is because of bishop takes D four.
And something that you should note down,
don't stop calculating just because you win
the rook on a eight. You have to make sure
that a situation doesn't arise where black
has already won one minor piece and is
likely to win a second one with B six.
Bishop B. Seven. So   this
is a very double edged position. But
you can avoid all of this
by doing the same thing in a different way.
94 to, uh, f three is incredibly strong.
Exactly.   It prevents
bishop takes D four and black has
no choice. Black has no choice
but to play a six.
Losing a healthy pawn in the endgame,
white should be technically winning
here. So that was the engine's
preferred choice. I didn't see night f three
from a distance, but I still like bishop C
four.   And the final opening note
that I'll make, the line in which bishop e
three is featured, if memory
serves me right, is this line
where black plays G
six,   which is a
viable subvariation of the D five
line. And after night F three, bishop
G seven, white again goes night ah, a
three. And there's an old line
where white plays C takes D four.
Now white plays bishop C
four. That's a move that we did
not play,   uh, in the
game. But the position is different. And
after queen e four, check. If you've never
seen this move before, it's an absolutely
stunning idea. What is white's move? White's
move is bishop to e three. This
is actual theory. And
who can figure out the idea after D
takes e three? What the heck is why doing
here. Well, like I said, anytime
there's a queen and it's in the center and
you're not very well developed, there's
going to be tactics,   but
not bishop e five. Check. I know some of you
are thinking, oh, uh, I see checkmate.
But the check on B five can be
easily parried with night C six.
No, no, no, the move is bishop takes
f seven, check. Stock tactic. And
if king f seven you get forked on G
five. And actually, most
importantly, if king f eight, you have
the additional check on D eight. Without
this check the whole line would fall apart.
Forcing king takes f seven and nine
g five check wins the queen with
checkmate.   So it's
a beautiful move bishop e three.
And because of the threat of, uh, bishop
takes f seven, black is forced to
spend a tempo getting the night out to age
six. And now White just recaptures on
T four. And according to modern theory,
white is better due to
his, uh, lead in development and just due
to the activity of white's pieces.
So just a cool thing to file
into your mental kind of rolodex. Bishop e
three is a known idea in
a different position. Ironically
enough. We of course played it in a much
simpler instantiation here. We don't have to
calculate anything because knight takes d
six just wins the game.    Um,
but king e seven is the decisive
mistake, no question about it. After night
takes d four, we are
already or sorry, bishop d six was the
decisive mistake here. We're already
completely winning. There's just no way that
Black can truly defend this
given the pathetic king situation.
Now, if
Magnus Carlson were sitting with the black
pieces, then after rook D eight, rookie one,
he would probably play the move queen g six.
And the game does continue here. A lot of
you pointed out knight f five, check. This
still does not work. It doesn't work because
of queen takes f five. And
even if you could play bishop C five,
it would still not work because of king e
eight. So again, in such
a position, it's so important to be patient.
Who can give me an example of a nice
solid, patient, improving move for White?
There is a couple of moves like that, but
let's see if you can generate a couple of
good alternatives here with White.
Yeah, love the move queen b three,
aiming the queen at B seven and aiming at e
six. Similarly, I love the move queen to f
three, get the queen onto a nice square and
then bring the rook to D one. Play it
simple. Now, queen f three might
be inaccurate because of queen g four and
this forces a queen trade, which obviously
is in Black's favor.    The engine
actually proposes a more brute force method.
It proposes the move bishop back to
d three in order to
eliminate the pin against the queen. And
open up the possibility now,
finally, of that check on f five, which
all of you wanted to deliver. Queen h five,
knight f uh, five check is clearly already
possible   because now, after e takes f
five, you have checkmates starting with
bishop c five. Oh, and look at
this, mate. Rookie seven,
queen a four stack, another
minor piece, check here,
check here and mate on
c four.
Amazing line. And just look at the
sorry state of black's pieces. This is all
you need to know.    So
lots of juicy, spicy lines like
this. Now, black
has a creative defensive idea
here. Queen takes f five,
bishop takes f five, rook eight takes d
one, rook takes d one. But what's
amazing is that black loses here,
because e f five, bishop c five is
literally double check. And mate, look at
how white's pieces are all in
perfect symphony here, coordinated
and depriving the king of all squares.
So incredible, uh,
lines here. And after
night f five. If black plays king f
eight, then oh my God,
look at the engine move here. This is
amazing.   Bishop d
three to e two.
Holy and I'm just going to throw
in the customer holy sword
because the rook is hanging on
d eight, right? So
black has to take the queen.
Now, a critical move for
white, you have to throw in the
intermezzo bishop c five check.
This forces the king
to move to g eight. And hopefully by now,
you see the idea if black goes king
e eight instead, then you go knight takes
g seven and you win everything.     But
after king g eight, you simply play rookie
takes the one with a double attack. You're
threatening checkmate, and you're
threatening to win the queen back. And black
cannot get all of the material back for the
queen. Black is going to be down in
exchange.   Incredible. Now, why
do you need bishop c five? Because if you
were to take immediately, then black wins.
After queen takes f five, you
can't play bishop c five anymore. And
rook d eight is now futile on account
of tingy seven. So at some
point, these games become tactical. And
when they do, you have to
calculate accurately. You have to be ready
to find creative solutions.
But hopefully, you know, this
this inspires you a little bit. These lines
aren't necessarily all that instructive, but
they just illustrate the potential that you
have when you patiently deploy
all of your pieces. So bishop d three
is the best move in the night f five to
follow. But the human move is something
like queen b three or queen f
three. Even a slow move like h three,
nothing wrong with this. This keeps a huge
advantage as well.
So in any case, e five, bishop g five
of course, ends the game immediately.
Just to reiterate, after queen g six, rook
takes e five, check, king f eight. And the
easiest winning move is knight to E six.
Checking up the rook on D eight. You simply
cannot survive if you're playing
black without developing any of your
pieces. Which is why if I'm playing black
here, I would go either queen G six or
maybe even night G six. Desperately trying
to bring your pieces into the game.
Anyways, e five. Bishop g
five. Our opponent gave up the queen and
F four. Not taking our foot off the gas
pedal. Knocking off the E five
pawn, opening up as many files as
possible and check mating with queen F
seven. Queen Gstum.
Pretty simple game,
but I think it led to a nice discussion
of Opening Theory. I'm starting to kind of
introduce to you the general tenets
of the Alipin Sicilian.
If you have a hankering for more
alapin content, you can find plenty of it
already on my YouTube channel. I've had so
many speed run games in the Allopin, and you
could just search by opening.
But we will have many more Alipins
and we will have a lot more discussion of
Opening Theory. For now, I think it's
a good time for us to end. I'm going
to probably put both of these games in the
same video. It's going to be a long one.
Um, or I might separate it. I'll
ask my editor what he thinks. But I hope you
guys enjoyed the two speedrun
games today. I think they were fun.
We're still   in the
area where the games are basically
straightforward and most of them are decided
in the opening, and that's going to be the
case for another 150 points, but that's
okay. That allows us to build a solid
foundation and talk about theory.
And, uh,   I hope you're enjoying the
games, even if they're one sided. Thank you,
everybody, for hanging out. And again, if
you aren't subscribed to my YouTube and you
want to support my content in an easy
way, the best thing to do is
to subscribe to the YouTube, keep growing
the channel. Thank you, everybody.
Have a good one and hopefully see you
tomorrow for more SEC Action
Rating. Hannah, thanks for hanging out, and
I'll see you guys later.
You.